let's go next to sarah from one of my
favorite cities in the world
montreal quebec canada sarah you're on
the air
hello can you hear me yes i can okay
uh so i guess i just wanted to know
what do you think about canada designing
the proud boys as a terrorist group
i think because yeah when i when i was
asked about it last week
i i obviously agreed colloquially but i
didn't understand
what it meant legally speaking in canada
and people have emailed me since and
explained that
by designating a a terrorist group it
actually
allows law enforcement more mechanisms
and leeway
for um pursuing and prosecuting the
group
and that it has legal significance in
canada so i agree with it
in the general sense and it sounds like
it will be useful to canada as well
yeah do you think there's gonna be any
similar things done like that in the
states or
you don't really think nothing's gonna
happen about that
i don't know i don't know i mean
obviously it's more likely that
a biden white house would push for
designating the proud boys as a
terrorist group
than in a trump white house i don't know
that it's a priority for the biden white
house to do that
okay uh other follow-up question because
they would talk about the
martial law in the u.s when the capital
thing happened right
i don't i don't know if you knew about
the law war was it the
missouri guy so it's like the war
measures were enacted in quebec in the
70s
and the army took control of the country
at the province because
of like terrorist group the flq i know
if you heard anything about that
i'm not familiar with that particular
incident but i've done some reading
about instances short-term instances
in many countries over the last 40 50
years where
there have been declarations where the
military does take over and
and see you know one of the problems
sarah is that when we look at historical
examples
there are many of historical examples of
uh martial law being declared
by authoritarian dictators who want to
remain in power
and then you also have examples where
there was a legitimate use and reason
for that declaration and so you really
have to look at the details of every
situation
yeah no for sure uh anyways i suggest
you look into it i know all the
information is mostly in french
yeah there's like a bias between the two
languages of how the enterprise
the events but uh if you have time uh
my french reading isn't bad you know
sometimes when i watch a french show
i will watch it with the french
subtitles and that's actually enough for
me to understand it
okay that's cool uh my favorite quebec
is kind of the communist hellscape
the u.s fears uh so i love quebec i have
to tell you it's so great there it's
such a you're it's it's the uh
it's such a european experience you know
yeah well one day the borders will open
again and you can come over
i would i would love to go and so are
you what general
area in montreal are you in uh i'm in
like the southwest so it's like verdurs
it's like very uh
working class kind of thing but um i'm
kind of like the uh
i guess yuppy which is like i work in
video games so i have a little bit of
money
i'm still full student debt so i live in
a kind of working class neighborhood
now south west that's not like the
atwater market right atwater market is
more like southwest
yeah it's like close to that it's
because montreal's directions are weird
because the north is the north of the
river
without the true north so everything is
really confusing for me
there's a similar thing in buenos aires
where what seem
oftentimes what is north on the map the
city is kind of rotated relative
to the river and so and in fact
manhattan is the same thing oftentimes
manhattan is portrayed as the avenues
running
perfectly north south but that's just
for visual aids
it's actually at an angle that's
interesting yeah it's it's
yeah it's a it's a weird things and
people get confused when they first come
in but
sarah one more question for you have you
ever been to the
vietnamese food stall at the atwater
market
uh i have not okay i highly recommend it
i highly recommend it
okay cool okay there's a lot of great
food montreal so there is it's like a
lot of food to eat
um but yeah thank you for taking my call
all right my pleasure sarah from
montreal great to hear from you
we're going to take a very quick break
but if you're holding on to talk to me
don't hang up unless you're furious that
i've not picked up your call already but
hang on because we're going to take a
few more calls right after the break